all right let's update you real quick on
simon cowell of course he broke his back
after falling off
his new electric bike just three days
ago
et has learned simon remains
hospitalized recovering from his
six-hour surgery
which included having a metal rod placed
in his back he is already starting to
walk again
as part of his rehab due to covet 19
simon can't have visitors but is
managing to do some work on his ipad
there is no timetable on when he could
return to agt
but he's happy about this week's fill in
hose for the first live show teddy clark
she's become a good friend over the
years on instagram american idol's first
winner joked
she is the quote wiser cooler and hotter
choice to take his seat
it's gonna look different than any other
previous year
i like that thrill of being on a roller
coaster i don't know what's coming
safe to say this is not the roller
coaster ride simon predicted
when i spoke with him less than 24 hours
before the accident
however way we do it we're gonna get a
show on air
so what can we expect tonight kelly will
appear in person not remote
alongside fellow judges sophia vergara
howie mandel and heidi klum
the whole team will shuttle around the
universal studios lot to watch the act
we have the theme park we have the
studio the spyro bros might be
in front of the you know harry potter's
castle or anything i mean it's going to
be super
exciting bigger than it's ever been i'm
not being worried about our hair
we're gonna be driving around also
expect
a stand-up set from former insider
correspondent michael yo
i don't know but it's gonna be crazy his
story is one of survival
after his first agt performance the dad
of two small children
contracted a near-deadly case of coveted
19. we almost lost it
that's the truth yeah and i'm so so
happy this is the redemption of the
century he came out victorious and i'm
so happy for him
you